some days it just hits me how amazing it
is that we all still live together and
what's really crazy is that you're still
in the house we all grew up in what are
the usually when you're still living in
your parents house after 30 years you'd
be considered a bunch of losers but we
don't pay rent so we're winners so many
things have changed in 30 years I know
who would have thought that I would fall
in love with Kimmy's brother and that
I'd be a bridesmaid at Steve's wedding
which tie do you like better who cares
no one looking at ground it's been 30
years since Uncle Jesse and Joey moved
in with us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and so sweet that you guys came up here
to celebrate the day we all became a
family and you're wearing the same
outfits actually I'm the only one
wearing the same out but these guys got
bigger sizes how rude in Japan you do
know that there's a really nice Benihana
right around the corner Jackson are you
ready to eat that history final I know
all the answers go ahead ask me anything
about Hamilton how do I get tickets it's
impossible that's correct he was really
getting married and not to you which is
fine if you happen to hate fairy tales
and happy ending
hey Jessie I need your help pretend
you're a cute guy ouch you know what I
mean pretend you're a young guy
[Music]
you're really wearing that to the
airport well answer her
[Music]
[Applause]
you